new research led by doctors from the
University of North Carolina and the
Institute of cancer research in London
shows women who have babies may have a
greater risk for breast cancer compared
to women without children the study
looked at data from nearly eight hundred
and ninety thousand women of different
ages they found the risk continues for
more than two decades after childbirth
our dr. David agus is director of the
USA Northwest Side cancer center in
California dr. egg it's good morning I'm
so glad you're here this morning because
I think the people will see this
headline and be alarmed but what can we
learn from this study it's an important
study I mean it shows that from the time
of last child for 24 years breast cancer
risk goes up its highest five years
after the child is born and it continues
to twenty four years and then it starts
to fall and its lowest at thirty five
years out so breast cancer is a disease
of 60s 70s and 80s and so by going up
early it does increase the risk but it's
more pronounced later on when breast
cancer is more common so why do you
think whoever this is not as scary as it
sounds
well because it's going to decrease your
risk 30 plus years out and so most
breast cancer happens 30 plus years out
so if you look cuman of Lee it decreases
the risks as breast cancer is relatively
rare in young women but this does change
our screening criteria and now we're
gonna ask when was your last child when
we determine your risk to determine if
you should be screened or not you think
this study is going to change how we
screen women for breast cancer I think
it certainly should if your last child
was at age 35 we may start screening of
age 40 instead of classically to age 50
because the risk may go up after five
years out and so it's very important now
that doctors asked this question and put
it into the history of the patient and
what is it about child birth that
increases the risk well we don't know
but obviously there's an estrogen surge
remember breast feeding in this study
had no protective effect in either
direction at all was a protective and
didn't cause risk but the estrogen surge
may cause breast cancer to prevent
earlier that's a hypothesis it certainly
hasn't been proven yet and if you have a
breast cancer history in your family
what about if you want to have a child
well in this case having a breast cancer
history or not didn't matter
in this study if you have a breast
cancer history you're at a higher risk
of breast cancer obviously you need to
be screened closer but this study
doesn't affect that and would you advise
women to do anything differently yeah I
want them to talk to the doctor and say
listen I have my last child at an older
age so maybe I should be screened
earlier because my risk is going to be
highest five years out from that point
so the discussion with the doctor is
critical to bring in this information
all right dr. David egg is always good
to have you thank you so much thank you
an important point to make as women are
having children later in life and so
starting to get our baseline at age 40
yes talk to your doctor